And of course we're absolutely keenly aware of that in the modern world because
we're possessed by this sense that all of our frenetic activity,
all of our frenetic motivated activity is producing alterations in the world
order such that nature itself is going to be destroyed and eliminate us,
right?
That's classic Sumerian fear and nothing's changed in the last 5,000 years.
The Sumerians presumed that once the elder gods were constructed and started
moving around on the planet,
that their activity,
they're mindless activity.
Because remember,
these aren't well integrated motivational forces.
They're more like primordial beasts right there.
Unintegrated activity risks plunging everything back and chaos.
Well tie match the representative of chaos,
this generative chaos.
But so what the Sumerian say?
Well,
the elder gods because a lot of racket,
they move around the planet and they upset time at and she decides that enough
is enough and she's going to wipe them out.
So she's sitting at the bottom of the ocean,
fuming away as the elder gods go about their business and then they take one
step too many and they kill Appsu.
Who's her husband?
Now,
the Sumerian creation myth doesn't say much about this,
but we know that Appsu is the male con sort of chaos that makes it mortar.
So what happens is the elder gods destroy order itself.
They destroy culture itself.
And as soon as you destroy culture,
all hell breaks loose.
And that's exactly what happens in this scenario creation myth.
So Tye,
Maddie,
Mergis,
she's going to wipe everything out and the world will revert back to its
primordial non-existence state.
Now the older guards get wind of this,
and of course they're just terrified because they know that this thing that gave
rise to them,
whatever it is,
the matrix of being can easily wipe them out at a moment's notice.
And so despite the fact that they're trans,
transpersonal,
and immortal,
and characterized by a certain amount of power in the face of absolute chaos,
they're insufficient.